erste erkenntnisse bei tönnies die
klimaanlage soll das corona virus in der
fleischfabrik verbreitet haben
prämien für die ausbildung die regierung
will unternehmen belohnen den der krise
weiterhin azubis beschäftigen
machtdemonstration trotz
ansteckungsgefahr russland gedenkt des
weltkriegs endes mit der größten
militärparade seiner geschichte
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster mit namen und willkommen
bei unseren blick auf die nachrichten an
diesem mittwoch mit von der partie
norbert lehmann für den sport einen
schönen guten beim doch familie tag eins
der wieder verschärften corona auflagen
in den kreisen gütersloh und warendorf
seit mitternacht ist das öffentliche
leben dort erheblich eingeschränkt grund
für die rückkehr zum strengen regeln ist
sehr großer ausbruch unter arbeitern im
schlachtbetrieb genius für die menschen
in den beiden westfälischen kreisen es
ist eine schwierige situation
insgesamt sind 600 40.000 einwohner
betroffen und noch kann niemand sagen ob
und wieweit das virus aus dem fleisch
betrieb in die bevölkerung
übergesprungen ist
deshalb muss nun massenhaft getestet
werden
und es gibt neue hinweise was den
ausbruch begünstigt hat thomas münten
berichtet es war offenbar die
klimaanlage im zerlegebetrieb des
fleischwerks zu diesem ergebnis kommt
der bonner hygiene experte martin exner
der die anlagen in dieser woche
untersucht hat was bisher nicht bekannt
ist
es ist das hier unter solchen
bedingungen um luft eine rose in
bewegung halten kann und dass das ein
weiterer bislang übersehene risikofaktor
ist mit uv-licht und hochleistungs
filtern könne man die viren beseitigen
so der mediziner weiter
die tests der mitarbeiter sind beendet
18 prozent der überwiegend
osteuropäischen kräfte sind allerdings
verschwunden
der wald stehen so viele bürger beim
kostenlosen massentest in gütersloh an
dass die kreisverwaltung ab mittag
niemand mehr aufnehmen konnte
die bürger sind ängstlich und sauer wir
wollen eigentlich eine kur antreten in
mecklenburg ich habe bis
bisher noch keine info bekommen von der
einrichtung dass es ein problem ist aber
ich dachte mir ich mach das mal
präventiv marion heidenfelder aus
gütersloh ist richtig geladen
sie war nach usedom bereist
ferienwohnungen und leih fahrrad bezahlt
doch der vermieter warf sie raus
die ganze fahrt habe ich nur immer
darüber nachgedacht dass ich es so schön
hatte da hinten die sonne schien
wunderbar und wir muss nach hause
mussten da gab es kein vertun
mecklenburg vorpommern schleswig
holstein niedersachsen und bayern haben
einreiseverbot für bürger aus warendorf
und gütersloh ohne testbericht erlassen
im besonders betroffenen turniers
schlachthof in gütersloh ist übrigens
jeder zweite arbeiter aus rumänien
die rumänische regierung fordert
deutschland nun auf die lebens und
arbeitsumstände ihrer staatsbürger
dringend zu verbessern um sie vor dem
virus zu schützen was uns zu der frage
an thomas münten bringt unter welchen
bedingungen eigentlich menschen bei uns
in deutschland arbeiten und leben müssen
gerade was diese leiharbeiter in der
fleischindustrie angeht sind die
bedingungen wirklich muss man sagen bei
einer unterirdisch in werl wo wir hin
der sürenheide in einem der häuser waren
da gibt es einen raum in der größe von
20 quadratmetern das hört sich jetzt
nicht klein an
darin liegen aber sechs matratzen die
arbeiter verdienen mindestlohn
jeder von ihnen muss aber allein für das
zurverfügungstellen der matratze 300
euro miete im monat bezahlen
das heißt derlei arbeitgeber verdient
damit noch mal 1800 euro die
lebensumstände sind äußerst bescheiden
es ist natürlich auch nicht besonders
sauber in diesen massenunterkünften die
häuser sind größtenteils
heruntergekommen wenn man das ändern
will
und das hat dann ja versprochen dann
wird das ein richtig teurer spaß werden
das wird nämlich mit diesen häusern gar
nicht zu machen sein versprochen worden
ist es allerdings schon öfter nur
umgesetzt leider bisher nicht
vielen dank thomas menschen in gütersloh
nicht nur in gütersloh und warendorf ist
die zahl der neuinfektionen sprunghaft
in die höhe geschnellt auch in magdeburg
göttingen und berlin neukölln gibt es
solche
aktuellen corona brennpunkte allein in
magdeburg befinden sich hunderte
bewohner im großen wohnblocks unter
quarantäne
andreas weise berichtet eine lieferung
sehnsüchtig erwartet die johanniter
bringen lebensmittel in die wohnblocks
im magdeburger norden die unter
quarantäne stehen notversorgung für mehr
als 800 menschen die meisten aus
rumänien die kommunikation oft schwierig
deshalb hat die stadt magdeburg seit
gestern axel wilhelms einen übersetzer
am sorgentelefon neben nahrung ist
wichtig die die das essen in dem haus
oft gang es nur gerecht verteilt werden
das muss mal schauen ob das auch
funktionieren wird sechs wochen ohne
neue infektionen bis anfang juni galt
magdeburg als corona frei dann mehr als
100 neue fälle vor allem unter den
rumänen oberbürgermeister trümper macht
gottesdienste verantwortlich die alles
andere als crooner konform gewesen sein
sollen anwesenheitslisten ohne nachnamen
adressen oder telefonnummern die
infektionsketten nicht mehr
nachvollziehbar
deshalb die quarantäne doch trümper weiß
auch um die prekären verhältnisse in den
wohnblocks dass viele um ihre zukunft
hier fürchten
und darum ist es auch verständlich was
der kollege meter am sonntag aus dem
fenster zu gerufen hat sorgen sie dafür
dass wir unseren job behalten wenn die
bedingung ist wenn ich keinen job habe
habe ich kein aufenthaltsrecht die
polizei gratuliert um die quarantäne
blogs zeigt präsenz zäune oder
zugangskontrollen gibt es aber nicht
magdeburg setzt noch auf die vernunft
der bewohner noch sind nur einzelne
städte und kreise von massiven neue
infektionen betroffen doch nun gilt es
die ausbreitung des virus über das ganze
land zu verhindern
wie entscheidend das ist zeigt der
bericht von auto anzuschieben
noch läuft er der betrieb in diesem
schlachthof in niedersachsen kreis
oldenburg die frage ist nur wie lange
noch denn auch hier haben sich
mitarbeiter mit dem corona virus
infiziert das ausmaß noch unklar
im moment werden mehr als 1.100
mitarbeiter getestet über die aktuelle
entwicklung haben
heute auch die gesundheitsminister der
länder beraten das ergebnis die
geltenden maßnahmen sollen erst mal
nicht verschärft aber konsequent
umgesetzt werden
wir sehen ja wenn man es diesen virus zu
leicht macht dann breitet es sich auch
ganz ganz schnell wieder aus das sehen
wir nicht nur in gütersloh das haben wir
in göttingen in leer in bremen gesehen
ob bei gottesdiensten oder
familienfeiern und deswegen ist immer
wieder wichtig deutlich zu machen ja die
zahlen waren jetzt niedrig über viele
viele wochen aber dieses virus ist noch
da durch die neuen corona hotspots
steigen die infektionszahlen in
deutschland weiter im durchschnitt der
vergangenen sieben tage haben sich
täglich 600 menschen mit dem corona
virus infiziert vor einer woche waren es
nur halb so viele
droht jetzt eine zweite welle also
zweite welle ist aufgrund der aktuellen
situation durchaus möglich weil wir
relativ viele kleine lokale oder kleine
und größere ausbrüche lokal sehen und
was getan werden muss um wirklich die
zweite welle zu verhindern ist dass
diese ausbrüche sehr stark und sehr
intensiv nachverfolgt werden
von seiten der behörden und auf der
anderen seite auch dass jeder von uns
weiterhin sich an die hygienemaßnahmen
hält vorsicht bleibt also das gebot der
stunde
am freitag wird klar sein wie es im
kreis oldenburg weiter geht dann sollen
alle testergebnisse der schlachthof
mitarbeiter vorliegen
die auswirkungen der pandemie zeigen
sich zunehmend auch auf dem
ausbildungsmarkt im vergleich zum
vorjahr wurden bisher deutlich weniger
lehrverträge für das im herbst
beginnende ausbildungsjahr abgeschlossen
deswegen hat die bundesregierung einen
schutzschirm von 500 millionen euro
beschlossen
firmen die trotz wirtschaftlicher
probleme weiter ausbilden sollen prämien
von zwei bis dreitausend euro pro
lehrling bekommen eva schiller berichtet
er will zudem versprechen stehen dass er
seinen auszubildenden gegeben hat ringt
aber gleichzeitig um die existenz seiner
stuttgarter restaurants tobias meyer
musste auf dem höhepunkt der krise seine
kaufmännische auszubildende entlassen
managt das büro jetzt alleine
trotzdem setzt er alles daran die acht
ausbildungsplätze im restaurant zu
retten
märz um schicksale und um
zukunftsperspektiven
selbst wenn ich als unternehmer keiner
habe so kann ich das ja nicht auch die
mitarbeiter übertragen und die azubis
also stehe ich dazu den wir eine art
eine ausbildung zugesagt haben die
bekommen diese ausbildung auch so
kämpferisch sind nicht alle in baden
württemberg wollen fast 30 prozent der
unternehmen corona bedingt nicht oder
weniger ausbilden die unsicherheit bei
vielen betrieben ist natürlich momentan
riesig denn die liquidität ist momentan
nicht da und gerade im bereich handel
gastronomie hotellerie ist es sehr
schwierig eine zukunftsprognose machen
zu können
ausbilden trotz corona davon will der
arbeitsminister unternehmen überzeugen
das kabinett hat eine azubi prämie auf
den weg gebracht zwei bis dreitausend
euro sollen kleine und mittlere betriebe
pro azubi bekommen
es ist wichtig jetzt ein signal in die
wirtschaft zu geben dass es kein corona
jahren gibt es das junge leute die jetzt
ins berufsleben starten wollen
kroner nicht als bleigewicht am bein
erleben für gastronomie ist die prämie
das richtige signal und gleichzeitig ein
tropfen auf den heißen stein
er kämpft mit vermietern und
versicherungen um die zukunft seiner
restaurants und seiner azubis zu sichern
die deutsche wirtschaft sieht ein licht
am ende des tunnels sagt das ifo
institut das jeden monat lage und
erwartungen von rund 9.000 unternehmen
erfasst
schauen wir uns mal den index an mit dem
virus sprach der pessimismus in
deutschlands chefetagen aus nun hält
sich die stimmung deutlich auf
allerdings nicht in allen unternehmen
wie florian kojak aus thüringen
berichtet
20 jahre lang liefen hier in
saalburg-ebersdorf nur autoteile vom
band beim thüringer unternehmen etm doch
dann kam der korona einbruch und ein
teil der produktion wurde umgestellt auf
wiederverwendbare schutzmasken mit
filter und das soll bleiben
wir versuchen es zum zweiten standbein
auszubauen wie erfolgreich das sein wird
das hängt natürlich von den
möglichkeiten ab wie wir uns jetzt im
auf den vertriebswegen noch eröffnen
aber ja es soll natürlich dazu beitragen
arbeitsplätze hier am standort zu
erhalten
im april waren von den 520 beschäftigten
hier 85 prozent in kurzarbeit
aktuell ist es noch jeder dritte eine
leichte entspannung also doch wann das
alte produktionsniveau wieder erreicht
werden kann ist derzeit völlig unklar
neben der auto zulieferer industrie sind
in thüringen auch andere branchen hart
getroffen
besonders gefährdet halte ich all die
unternehmen deren leistungen am tag der
erstellung konsumiert werden also
restaurantbetriebe tourismusbetriebe
veranstaltungsmanagement weil die keine
chance haben drüber nachholenden konsum
den aus dass irgendwie zu kompensieren
das spüren die eventmanager alexander
theiss und steffen fetzner aus erfurt
150 veranstaltungen hatten sie für
dieses jahr geplant alle abgesagt heißt
keine einnahmen für die unternehmer
trotz laufender kosten in absehbarer
zeit weiter geht und das ist halt die
große angst die magath haben als
inhaltlich ganz eingemachte geht also
das ganze erlebnis werk war sie ist dann
weg sie hoffen dass ihre mitarbeiter
schnellstmöglich zurück an ihre
schreibtische können und ihre stars
wieder auf die bühne
die bundesregierung will ab sommer 2021
ein weg plastik verbieten
damit setzt sie eine eu-verordnung um
dann werden etwas strohhalme
wattestäbchen oder besteck aus plastik
aus dem handel verschwinden
stattdessen soll stärker auf mehrweg
produkte gesetzt werden
kritiker warnen allerdings dass solche
produkte nicht automatisch
umweltfreundlich sein
nach moskau der 75 jahrestag des sieges
über hitler deutschland ein bedeutender
termin
für russland kein land hatte mehr opfer
im krieg zu beklagen als die damalige
sowjetunion eine militärparade war
geplant für den 9
dann kamen corona dazwischen heute wurde
die parade nachgeholt obwohl russland
immer noch von der pandemie gebeutelt
ist christian senn über einen in vieler
hinsicht besonderen jahrestag
eigentlich sind in moskau
massenveranstaltungen ja verboten wegen
corona
das gilt aber nicht für putins
inszenierung die große militärparade
13.000 soldaten marschieren für
mindestabstand kann platz dazu panzer
raketen und internationale gäste aus
kasachstan belarus serbien oder china
ein wichtiger tag vor allem für
präsident putin im 75 jahre nach
kriegsende
der preis für die befreiung europas war
entsetzlich hoch viele hunderttausende
sind auf fremdem boden gefallen es ist
unsere pflicht daran zu erinnern und
auch daran dass der sowjetische volk die
hauptlast gegen den faschismus getragen
die parade trotz sieben bis 8000 coroner
neuinfektionen jeden tag in russland
doch putin gerade im umfragetief wollte
die für den 9 mai geplante parade
unbedingt nachholen
die veteranen wurden extra zwei wochen
in quarantäne geschickt auf moskaus
straßen weniger zuschauer als sonst aber
ganz eng zusammen
es ist zu früh um die parade abzuhalten
meiner meinung nach hätte man mindestens
noch einen monat warten müssen
dieses jahr sind wir in die stadt
gekommen mit unseren kindern um alles
mit eigenen augen zu sehen
das ist ein wichtiges und bedeutendes
ereignis für alle russen und für unsere
familie besonders ein startschuss soll
die parade sein um putins macht zu
festigen
ab morgen stimmen die russen über
weitreichende verfassungsänderungen ab
die macht der bilder soll helfen um gute
stimmung zu verbreiten
zu einer affäre die österreich
erschüttert hat seit das berühmt
berüchtigte ibiza video die politik
durch durcheinandergewirbelt hat steht
der verdacht der korruption im raum den
ehemaligen spd vize kanzler strache
hauptdarsteller im video hat das amt und
karriere gekostet aber auch kanzler kurz
vom ex koalitionspartner vp musste sich
heute unangenehme fragen gefallen lassen
im untersuchungsausschuss in wien britta
hilpert berichtet ein kanzler vor dem
untersuchungsausschuss das gab es in
österreich schon aber die medien menge
zeigt diesmal ist es besonders denn das
ebita video war nur der anfang von
weiteren enthüllungen zu postenschacher
und parteispenden ihn dazu zu befragen
der kanzler für unnötig vorweg auch
schon angekündigt habe ich natürlich
wenig beizutragen
zudem auf ibiza gesagten weil ich selbst
hier nicht in ibiza war im ibiza video
zeigte sich der spätere
regierungspartner strache offen für
korruption als das publik wurde sprengte
das die regierung wer wen auf welchen
posten hievte hat beide noch zusammen
auf der regierungsbank saßen das wurde
heute nachgefragt kurz legte dazu weder
kalenderdaten noch sms vor weil die
regelmäßig gelöscht werden strache hat
mir manchmal mehr sms geschrieben als
ich lesen konnte
normalerweise sagt der kanzler wer
nichts zu verbergen hat hat auch nichts
zu befürchten ich würde sagen wer nichts
zu verbergen hat hat nichts zu löschen
fünf stunden wurde kurz befragt auch
kontrovers gefährlich wurde es ihn nicht
der ausschuss tag für bundeskanzler
sebastian kurz war unangenehm aber ohne
bleibenden schaden
es war unangenehm zu erklären wie man
als
teil von parteispenden rankommt wie sich
regierungsparteien posten vergaben
ausmachen und dem ministerrat
wechselweise durchwinken
es war aber nichts neues doch die causa
ibiza bleibt unangenehm der ausschuss
läuft noch monate ja nun zu dir norbert
und clemens tönnies der steht ja auch
nicht nur als fleischfabrikant unter
druck da ist ja auch der
aufsichtsratsvorsitzende von schalke 04
und hat inzwischen einen schweren stand
bei den fans der verein steckt in einer
tiefen sportlichen krise nach 15
sieglosen spielen und der unmut der s04
anhänger der hat noch weitere gründe
mit bannern bringen die fans unmut zum
ausdruck der club verkaufte seine werte
die saison sei eine moralische
bankrotterklärung im zentrum der kritik
die vereinsführung und aufsichtsratschef
clemens tönnies links schalke hat fast
200 millionen euro schulden der plan die
profiabteilung als kapitalgesellschaft
auszulagern
für viele fans ein rotes tuch auch die
farce um härtefall anträge bei der
rückerstattung von tickets ärger die
anhänger am samstag wollen sie rund ums
stadion in einer menschenkette mit
abstand demonstrieren unter anderem weil
clemens tönnies schalke führt wie sein
schlachthof da werden
mitbestimmungsrechte mit füßen getreten
und das alles ist auch schlecht für das
image von schalke 04
der vorstand um alexander jobst und
jochen schneider ließ verlautbaren man
wolle im dialog vertrauen für eine
bessere zukunft zurückgewinnen
in schalkes gegenwart aber brodelt es
zum finalturnier der basketball
bundesliga erst haben sie den
titelverteidiger bayern münchen aus dem
wettbewerb geworfen
jetzt können sie selbst titelgewinner
werden ludwigsburg steht im endspiel
nach dem sieg gestern abend gegen
riesenfreude bei ludwigsburg erster
final einzug der klubgeschichte dabei
dominiert zunächst ulmen 33 20 deutliche
führung des bei diesem turnier bislang
ungeschlagenen teams
ludwigsburgs trainer patrick fordert in
der pause mehr kampfgeist erfolgreich
seine mannschaft macht die ersten neun
punkte der zweiten hälfte ist nun
überlegen auch dank des treffsichersten
spieler der partie
26 punkte für markus
entstand 94 zu 85 ludwigsburg träumt
jetzt sogar vom titel
finalgegner am freitag bei oldenburg
oder berlin die spielen heute abend
gehen wir bleiben sportlich und schauen
jetzt auf eine show der besonderen art
besonders wegen dieser kulisse die
schweizer alpen als bühne für
körperkunst in schwindelerregender höhe
besonders auch weil die artisten eine
botschaft haben
vergesst in der korona krise nicht die
künstler und akrobaten denn keine
auftritte heißt für sie kein einkommen
anlass genug für den extremsportler
freddy nock drei neue weltrekorde
aufzustellen
und wir haben noch die lottozahlen für
sie die gewinnzahlen lauten 5 11 18 34
38 41 und die superzahl 3 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
keinen ganz ungetrübten sonnenschein
sagt gleich katja con horneffer für
morgen vorher sie im osten drohen einige
schauer und gewitter wie es für den rest
aussieht dazu gleich mehr
mehr auch von christian sievers später
im heute journal um viertel vor zehn
das war es von uns für heute danke für
ihre aufmerksamkeit und haben sie noch
einen schönen sonnigen abend bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren das
tief rosemarie schickt uns einige
wolkenfelder von polen auch nach
tschechien und nach österreich und da
gibt es bei uns halt auch einige
regenschauer und gewitter sonst war es
in mitteleuropa meist wolkenlos nur wenn
den pyrenäen da entwickelten sich hier
am nachmittag noch einige größere
gewitter das sehen sie an diesen weißen
kreisen das sind die zellen schirme der
gewitter bei uns allerdings fällt regen
also zwischen dem südlichen brandenburg
und dem erzgebirge aber auch in der
oberpfalz und in niederbayern
sonst ist die nacht klar und die
temperaturen sinken meist auf 17 bis
neun grad berlin ist eine ferne insel
dort wird nicht kühler als 18 grad und
morgen klettern die temperaturen an der
ostsee auf 26 und bis auf 31 grad am
niederrhein
kühler bleibt es zwischen dem thüringer
wald und dem alpenrand aus der nacht
heraus können sich noch einige
regenschauer und gewitter hier zwischen
dem mecklenburger seenplatte und dem
harz entwickeln richtung küste aber
strahlt die sonne genau so wie im
emsland und entlang des rheins in
süddeutschland beschränkten sich
einzelne regenschauer und gewitter hier
auf die oberpfalz und niederbayern am
freitag passiert zweierlei einerseits
ziehen von polen regenschauer und
gewitter richtung ostsee und von
südwesten wird es gewittrig und am
samstag bleibt ist für uns dann
gewittrig schönen abend noch